je vais vous raconter une petite
anecdote quand même messieurs du
rassemblement national écoutez bien un
jour je vais je vais dans un je n'ai été
interpellé que par des hommes sur cette
question madame pardon je vous ai pas
entendu ce n'est pas du sexisme
voyez-vous un jour je rentre dans un
centre éducatif fermé monsieur le député
écoutez bien puis il y a un gamin
totalement prostraite qui est là vous
voyez la formule de Sian je m'accroche
désespérément à ma mauvaise étoile je
préfère pleurer Margot mais il est
orphelin il a connu des situations
extraordinairement complexes qui l'ont
amené entre autre chose à il est dans un
coin il est totalement prostré et puis
j'essaie de lui parler il répond pas et
j'essaie de m'intéresser à lui parce que
oui je suis aussi le ministre des
mineurs qui sont dans les CF et il y a
laissez-moi terminer écoutez bien si on
pouvait si on pouvait en finir avec ça
écoutait bien écoutez moi 2 secondes et
là il y a un baby-foot et je lui dis
mais viens à côté de moi et vous sortez
les photos écoutez bien et avec une
forme de de vulgarité qui parfois
caractérise les uns et les autres vous
dites voilà comment le garde des sceaux
s'occupe de la délinquance des mineurs
alors voyez je vais vous dire j'ai envie
de vider mon sac parce que ça il y a
tellement longtemps que je le porte ce
gosse il fallait que je le frappe
monsieur le député il fallait que je lui
donne des coups de pied dans les côtes
c'est ça que vous vouliez
c'est ça que vous vouliez ça c'est la
signature de votre humanisme à vous
ouais ouais